[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département et mercredi 12 juillet
parole ali chargé de
développement pour la section yvelinoise
du secours populaire français
l'association largement impliqué pour
permettre à tous de partir en vacances
de nombreuses actions sont encore
prévues cet été
paroles aussi dans cette émission à
michel augier de président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et maire de montigny le
bretonneux
il ne cache pas son inquiétude
concernant la suppression prévue de la
taxe d'habitation dès 2018 80% des
foyers devraient être concernés par la
mesure d'ici trois ans aline grillons
bonsoir mon chemin vous êtes je le
disais chargé de développement pour le
secours populaire français dans la
section et blinoise vous venez tout
juste de lancer la campagne des vacances
pour cet été on va revenir largement
dessus d'abord je voulais vous faire
réagir peut-être sur un chiffre qui
marque énormément les esprits sains en
france surtout sur trois aujourd'hui en
france ne part pas du tout en vacances
est ce que vous savez peut-être avec
votre expérience is it un chiffre qui se
maintient comme ça très négatif depuis
des années ou alors qui a tendance à
baisser jusque là la situation
s'améliore pour les enfants français
j'ai envie de dire les choses
la situation stagne en tout cas
et ça fait de nombreuses années qu'en
fait on constate qu'il ya des enfants et
des familles qui ne peuvent pas partir
en vacances et donc depuis la création
de l'association c'est un des vecteurs
marquant de nos activités qui permet à
chacun de pouvoir un peu sortie à nos
quotidiens à s'évader
oui j'allais vous demandez quelle était
l'importance pour des enfants même si on
les imagine facilement mais en quoi
c'est très important pour eux de pouvoir
partir en vacances
déjà cette fois ça la première de voir
autre chose que
leur quotidien on a des familles où les
enfants habitant un enfant avec un
parent à 5 dans une seule pièce c'est un
peu compliqué donc sa femme est serré ça
permet aux enfants de pouvoir s'aérer de
pouvoir découvrir d'autres choses et un
montant de pouvoir avoir un peu de repos
pour les parents aussi
pendant ce temps là un point auquel les
enfants sont partis ce qui est important
aussi peut-être c'est de revenir avec
des souvenirs en septembre avoir des
choses aussi à raconter ça doit pas être
facile des premiers jours à la rentrée
quand on me raconte ses vacances c'est
que ce soit on n'est pas parti se voit
aussi serré quand on connaît la la
rédaction de rentrer ou de ce qu'on a
fait pendant les vacances ou est-ce
qu'on est parti avec les enfants qui ne
partent pas nous ont rien à dire du coup
le fait de vos leur permettre de pouvoir
avoir une journée de sortie ou des
vacances à raconter c'est toujours un
plus pour les enfants
et puis j'ai beaucoup la majorité des
enfants sont en vacances ne revienne
avec les yeux qui pétillent voix ils
partent avec les yeux qui pétillent
quand même des partis donc les parties
reviennent avec les yeux qui appétit
alors vous le secours populaire français
vous intervenez là dessus pour essayer
de lutter contre cette injustice là vous
mener différentes actions tout le long
de l'année et cet été à commencer par
les séjours copains des vacances c'est
ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer un peu
le concept de ces vacances copains le
contenu de ces vacances de commander à
l'avancé que les c'est le le but est
d'avoir en fait un copain de plus qui
partent avec les familles en vacances
donc en fait la famille accueille
bénévolement
un ou deux enfants prend ses vacances
donc c'est des familles qui partent en
vacances et qui emmène quelqu'un voilà
un choix des familles des yvelines qui
partent en vacances et quand même un
enfant 2 soit des familles de provence
ou même de suisse et des pays bas qui
accueillent dans leur région en fête des
enfants du secours populaire
ça permet de partir en vacances
découvrir des paysages et puis de se
faire aussi des amis le lien social ça
ça se joue aussi là dessus ça doit
rentrer en considération j'imagine un
pool et d'enfants et ça a joué beaucoup
et même pour les nous les familles de
vacances raconte aussi que ça apporte
beaucoup dans son pays d'accueil et ça
leur apporte aussi beaucoup à l aimons
beaucoup il ya un véritable échange qui
se construit et c'est pour ça qu'on
appelle ça le comprendre les vacances
des enfants du coup en fait l'enfant
accueilli et plus qu'un enfant accueilli
c'est vraiment un copain de vacances et
on a au moins un tiers des enfants
chaque année qui était invité par la
même famille a eu des liens qui se
nouent
il ya donc derrière l'enfant qui
racontaient qu'ils retrouvaient dans sa
famille de danseurs et qui redonnait
voir sa mémé de vacances très même sa
mémé cinq ans
c'est difficile parce que forcément vous
avez besoin d'avoir des familles
volontaires pour faire c'est ce que
c'est difficile d'en trouver ce que vous
avez du mal chaque année à renouveler
l'offre ou alors mine de rien les les
yvelinois sont assez généreux et offrent
leurs vacances leurs services au secours
populaire français
en fait c'est maintenant la proposition
d
une personne qui baise c'est surtout la
durée du séjour on sait qu'avant on
avait beaucoup de familles qui se
proposait d'accueillir trois semaines
pour accueillir un enfant est là en fait
c'est plus baissé à 10 15 jours en fait
que les modalités des avances des gens
pour eux mêmes déjà à changer dont
beaucoup y officie réduisent l'accueil
mais déjà le fait d'avoir des familles
qui a accueilli 10 15 jours pourrait
déjà plutôt intéressant et on a cette
année plus d'enfants qui partent par
tunis positif 1 au global que l'an
dernier alors d'autres actions vous
emmener plusieurs on va les sites et
peut-être un peu plus rapidement puisque
le temps presse il ya notamment le
centre de vacances on va dire entre
guillemets une colonie et puis il ya
aussi des séjours pour les familles là
c'est vous aider des familles qui sont
en difficultés au quotidien à partir en
vacances qu'est ce que vous leur
apporter concrètement vie alors on leur
apporte les ya des familles qui vous
souhaite avoir des séjours en pension
complète transport etc
puis d'autres qui ont besoin qu'on les
accompagne pour avoir accès à des
hébergements à moindre coût donc en fait
on permet aux familles principalement
durant l'été mais on a aussi fait on a
aussi organisé au niveau national un
séjour pour 4 100 personnes au roman une
canne de l'attention de l'ascension pour
lancer un peu le les séjours laisser
jouer avec tout ce qu elle est
et non beaucoup et au sein de familles
chinoises qui ont participé à ce séjour
là à tarnos dans les landes
et sinon pendant l'été donc les familles
peuvent partir comme tout le monde dans
le dix membres de vacances ça renforce
les liens c'est bon pour pour toute la
famille c'est bon pour les enfants pour
les parents
là aussi de s'aérer de passer à autre
chose alors ça leur donne effectivement
de pouvoir s'évader et puis quand ils
sont en pension complète du coup les
parents n'ont pas à faire à brancher et
je la fais à la renverse à l'apa mais
aussi une pouvoir eux se reposer un peu
et puis quand il ya des clubs enfants du
coup les gamins peuvent s'amuser
donc ça va renforcer un peu les gains et
de pouvoir se reposer pendant une
semaine et il ya eu au moins un enfant
un jour qui a dit j'ai pu voir ma mère
rire pour la première fois voilà donc
comprendre l'importance de réellement
que partir maintenant ce que ce soit en
famille ou pas forcément quand c'est
dans une famille d'accueil
un dernier mot maintenant sur sur cette
première cet été peut-être en rapport
avec les 50 ans du secours populaire
français dans les yvelines le village
copains du monde
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer un
petit peu et très rapidement
malheureusement ce concept qui a lieu la
semaine prochaine sur l'île de loisirs
alors ces animaux donc existe depuis
plusieurs années au niveau du secours
populaire et c'est la première fois
qu'on organise cette année dans le cadre
des 25 ans une coupe du monde est né ce
important de la fédération et le
principe ce qui est des enfants
européens et des français qu'ils
puissent se rencontrer durant une
semaine autour d'activités ludiques y
ait une visite culturelle pour échanger
pour pouvoir des échanges autour d'un
séjour et puis on rappelle que ce soit
pour ses activités d'été ou pour le
reste de l'année les initiations baptême
de l'air initiation au bmx les sorties
tour ici que vous organisez vous avez
évidemment besoin de bénévoles ou de
dons et qu'on peut faire un don ou ce
par sms notamment désormais et on peut
se rendre pour plus d'informations sur
le site qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
secours populaire point fr merci à l'ina
grillon d'être venu en plateau merci
pour vos réponses
bon courage et puis bel été à vous merci
beaucoup merci à vous c'était une
promesse de campagne d'emmanuel macron
le président de la république a confirmé
qu'il souhaitait réformer la taxe
d'habitation et ce dès l'an prochain
celle-ci sera à terme supprimer pour 80%
des français
une bonne nouvelle il semblerait pour
les habitants mais un coup porté aux
finances des collectivités des mairies à
saint quentin en yvelines les
inquiétudes sont nombreuses comme nous
l'expliqué michel auger président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux il répondait aux
questions de miquel et demi d'euros et
charline hurel le maire de montigny le
bretonneux excusez moi de répondre aux
questions de michael et demi d'euros et
charline hurel je suis avec michel
laugier le maire de montigny le
bretonneux ensemble nous allons parler
de la réforme qui agite en ce moment un
peu les maires des communes la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation vous
michel auger qu'est ce que vous en
pensez cette suppression de la taxe
d'habitation déjà là pour deux choses
moi chaque fois qu'ils n réforme
je suis toujours très soucieux et je
trouve que tout est fait encore dans la
précipitation
j'avais aussi la même analyse losc
on a parlé de la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle et je veux dire il s'est
avéré que ce qui a été produit c'est une
usine à gacé qui en fait n'a pas rempli
sa mission
à part peut-être pour de très grandes
entreprises pour le reste les
entreprises moyennes de l'est les pme
les tpe
eh bien on continuer à payer peut-être
même plus d'impôts plus de taxes et en
plus aussi s'appliquer aux professions
libérales envoyé cette réforme là on a
beaucoup parlé
il faut avancer les fang accouche d'une
souris puisque ce n'est pas une bonne
réforme
la repart encore vers une informe de la
taxe d'habitation la taxe d'habitation
seca même l'impôt l'impôt local par
excellence qui s'appliquent sur une
commune qui s'adresse à l'ensemble de la
population
l'ensemble des habitants mais là c'est
encore pareil on lance une réflexion
fonctionne pas de réfection ont dans une
réforme sans qu'ils aient vraiment de
réflexion sans guillemets un travail
fait avec les élus locaux
aucune concertation voilà on va imposer
quelque chose qui dès dont l'esprit
d'une personne dont le cadre d'une
élection présidentielle dont je trouve
ça un peu dramatique et comment faire
justement pour vous en tant que commune
pour lutter contre voilà cette baisse de
dotation nouvelle fois des écoutes et
j'espère que on va voir une réaction de
la part des élus et puis ensuite je
pense que les parlementaires seront là
aussi pour ça je pense bien sûr à nos
députés je pense surtout à nos sénateurs
qui représente bien sûr les
collectivités territoriales j'espère que
là y aura un vrai travail qui sera fait
et puis surtout qu'on arrête de faire
n'importe quoi vous pensez qu'il peut y
avoir des pétitions peut-être lancé
dans les toute la france au niveau des
mers août et où je pense que ce soit des
pétitions qu'il faut faire pour qu'on
pense surtout qu'il faut chacun mais
prennent bien conscience que que bercy
ne fasse aussi des projections sur ceux
qui resteraient pour les communes
aujourd'hui compétents on est au des
grands seigneurs
on compense ce que l'on en aura plus
dans des voies des communes
il savait une compensation elle sera
établie sur une année et puis je pense
que au fil du temps elles vont diminuer
et d'eau conclusion ce sont encore les
communes qui vont payer les pots cassés
si j'allais dire mais quand je dis à
travers les communes ce sont les
habitants ce que les ceux qui ne vont
pas payer un endroit ils vont le pays a
d'autres vous êtes également président
du coup de saint quentin en yvelines
est ce que ça peut jouer aussi au niveau
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est beaucoup plus évident pour une
ville pour une commune un peu moins
évident pour la commération mais ce sont
encore là des recettes et des marges de
manoeuvre qui dit qu'ils vont
disparaître pour les collectivités
jusqu'à présent nous étions libres de
faire ce que nous souhaitions haut
niveau par exemple de la taxe
d'habitation
c'est nous qui en fiction le taux
sedouki affection une augmentait sur une
diminution donc là aujourd'hui ça va 12
nous échapper on va nous compenser donc
par des dotations qui seront toujours
fixe donc il ya des ya des communes par
exemple qui devant plus pouvoir financer
une partie de leur service
donc forcément s'il ya un budget qui
sera inférieure il y aura sûrement à
l'évidence dans certaines villes des
services à la population qui vont
diminuer
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités
pour ce soir prochain rendez vous demain
et dernier rendez-vous de la saison en
attendant retrouvez toutes nos séquences
sur tv soixante dix huit points faux
l'application tv 78 excellente soirée à
tous
[Musique]